[Music]
welcome to another episode of the addie
hour today i'm honored and privileged to
host sean astin for a conversation about
mental health resources advocacy and
support sean's someone who's probably
known to all if not or many if not all
of you but i'm going to go ahead and
give them a really brief introduction
so sean aston is an american film actor
director voice artist producer who's
best known for his roles in films like
the lord of the rings trilogy the
goonies of course rudy and also in the
netflix series stranger things too he's
the son of academy award winning actress
patty duke and acclaimed actor john
astin he's also won several different
awards the lord of the rings trilogy
garnered eight or eleven excuse me
eleven academy awards um and sean also
has taken home awards for
he had the standard award for best
supporting actor awards from the las
vegas film critic society the seattle
film critics the utah film critics
association and the phoenix film critic
society so obviously someone who's
talented in his in his field and in his
vocation he's also a long-distance
runner he's been a long-distance runner
since his teens and in 2012 actually
launched a twitter campaign hashtag run
third as a way to dedicate his runs to
causes and ideas that matter not only to
him but to others as well
he's a ucla graduate who has served on
the board of several different national
nonprofit organizations including the
national center for family literacy he's
a vocal advocate for literacy mental
health awareness bipolar disorder civic
engagement and several other issues so
i'm honored to welcome sean aston to the
addie hour podcast thanks so much for
being here
it was so nice to hear you read all that
i just made it feel so i don't know
substantial somehow that's that's nice
thank you for that it is substantial
substantial and real
it's real it's real
but definitely appreciate you know all
the work that you've done over the years
in so many different spheres not just in
terms of obviously your talent
on screen and off screen but also just
the way you've been a real advocate for
mental health and i know there's a story
there that we'll get into as well but as
my listeners know i often just like to
check in and kind of see how my guests
are doing in the midst of everything
that we're facing in this ever changing
world and emerging trying to emerge from
kovitz so just want to start there and
see how you're doing these days overall
well thank you for that as uh if people
are watching this i'm currently sitting
in a little um
cottage in sweden
and uh they're any at any moment i i
fully expect one of these big uh they're
like cruise ships that go by they're not
well they're like dinner crews but
they're the size of big cruise ships um
i am
back
to
life i would say you know
i went and made a movie in louisiana and
in the film industry there's all sorts
of coveted protocols that films take um
and but it was weird it was definitely
weird to do that first sort of you know
i i was
at the airport with crowds and in the
airport shuttle to the rental car with
you know crowded buses and just thinking
what
you know what has happened to my
consciousness this is this is it's not
just
fear of
um
you know of getting coveted it's it's
also
my relationship all of our relationship
to each other into the outside world and
so that was a a culture shock after a
year and a half and then then when i
came back my wife and kids are like you
can't come in yet you have to stay next
door you have to get like an airbnb for
a few days so you can be tested and
so i did that and now i'm over here
doing these um conventions that are like
autograph
um
you know science fiction uh fantasy
comic book you know comic-con kind of
conventions so they're it's a lot of
people so it's gonna be and i did it in
sweden and then i'm gonna do uh wales
so i don't know i feel like the
treadmill has started back up i'm back
on it um you know i'm getting this uh
masters in a public administration
public policy from american university
and i am spending all of my uh
discretionary time
on on you know
reading and studying and quizzes and
midterms and all that so life is good
life is good it's the best is that i'm
able to like get outside and do long
walks and stuff so but
it's it's hard the hardest part is
family is managing um family but
everybody seems to be
in a mode you know the the the middle
kid
is um so i've got three daughters ali
elizabeth and bella allie lives with her
boyfriend and they have their own place
now they were with us for a long time
during covet and then they got their own
place and then the elizabeth is still at
home she's a pepperdine and she's still
at home
so wait i'm figuring any minute that'll
be both she and the youngest one who's
16 are at home so
it's going to be amazing to see what
happens when we're no longer living in a
submarine environment you know where you
just uh where you're outside of our
cohort um and i who knows what that
holds in store but life is good long
answer to a short question
i appreciate that honesty and just
taking us through that journey too i
mean it sounds like some of it's pacing
too you know as you know the family's
kind of all been together i'm assuming
more often than before from the way that
you've characterized it but even as
you're emerging
i actually for a long time i would
mourn the end of covet because it would
likely mean that we'd never spend that
kind of close time together ever again
um so in that sense as a father who and
a guy who traveled around
all you know so many weeks out of the
year
the idea that i i kind of liked it
you know i kind of i kind of liked it
but you can you can tell that the
long-term impact is not ultimately
healthy we you know they have to be with
friends and they have to be we all have
to be with friends we all have to
move our bodies around and and um but
it's
you know we know our personalities now
so well you know we you can almost do
like handshake hand gestures a little
facial you know like oh that one just
came down and you know you can tell that
you know they're in the mood leave them
alone you know
yeah yeah did that catch you off guard
do you think you have a like you and
your family have more of an appreciation
for that now or was that
something that you think was always
there and
just kind of continued well they they
all had their ecosystem
and i would come in and out of the
ecosystem based on my travels and all
the work i was doing yeah so
i definitely felt
their
little cocoon expanded to include me
during it
um but then in a weird way you know i
started doing from home
work with my union you know zoom kind of
made lots of things possible that
weren't possible beforehand so i i
applied to american university i started
doing this thing and a weird way we kind
of like went to our
mental neutral corners anyway yeah and
even though we were i wanted to learn
the guitar so i'd be upstairs you know
with the door closed playing guitar and
it's amazing after ten thousand hours of
guitar playing how bad i still am
and they're very patient you know
they'll come up to go to bed and i'm
like you gotta listen to this song you
know that yeah i'm not gonna listen to
that
um but no we we
for a while when kovitz started we all
ate
sort of like regular meals together like
normal people
but then we kind of all live like we're
in a fish tank or you know like we all
just kind of
graze and do what we're doing so i would
sort of it's amazing how we've
we've
settled
back into like where we were beforehand
in a lot of in a lot of ways yeah well
it sounds like you all were flexible too
i mean you kind of readjusted
in this movie we were lucky we were
lucky
i will forever be grateful for our
particular circumstance in this
sort of thing you can see the rhythms
of your day and your week and your month
you can see your family rhythms you can
see your own psychological rhythms you
know why on one day am i feeling totally
claustrophobic uh and like i have to get
out and there's no reason to but uh and
other days no there's you know we want
to go for a drive just to get a sense of
what's going on in the outside world so
like we're in the mars rover and we're
going out to explore you know and and
like what
how do we
you know no one got hurt
physically
i wondered about that a lot like what
happens if somebody falls down the
stairs or cuts themselves or has some
other
you know
breaks a tooth or i don't know something
like it's been a blessing that nobody's
been
really injured over the course of the
time but because of that
we've basically been in this little
behavioral experiment
and
you know i
yeah i mean i think we'll be unpacking
it for the rest of our lives i as our
family member i've been the sort of
first to go
and uh
and so and they
you know we have this long talk about
like you're going to go into this movie
and then you're going to come back and
you're going to be like there's no such
thing as covid let's just keep going i'm
probably because it was in the south
where i was working but but they uh
but i said no you know of course i'll be
respectful and it's all about mass and
all doing we're supposed to do
but when i came back i started looking
at them and judging them a little bit
wow like you guys you can't your your
your paradigm is you're in a locked
paradigm that's not in your own interest
you've got to break out of it and they
and then there was like this
this civil war in that this this cold
civil war in our house about you know
whether what what it's time to do and
and not do but i you know i'm taking
this economics class and i'm sure we're
supposed to like
come up with uh you know things in
everyday life that reflect some of the
economics
you know principles that we're studying
and one of the things like my whole life
i've as a as a parent
it's been about saving money for their
college
that's been my my life to save money for
college save money for college and uh
we've been lucky to do it some years we
couldn't other years we could but by the
time the first one by the time ali got
ready to go to college
we've we've been able to kind of be
there but now that elizabeth is in her
second year at pepperdine her whole
first year virtual
and you're looking at this bucket of
money
that you worked so hard to save
over two decades basically
and you go boy
i've never thought about this before but
you're like well i can just park that
money in a house
i just buy her a house
and somehow and and you you so you start
looking at like
what are she joined a sorority
but she
she
knew that it wasn't okay that we're so
segregated from people so she did it as
a way to make sure that she had
this virtual community so that when we
come out of it she'll be able to go back
into it which is just very sensible but
it seemed to me
that
that activity
that discretionary activity that is
so outside of her normal
mode
is the thing that's worth not buying the
house for
i wanted to go to college but my
my world view has has you know just
paused to allow other things to come
into it what do we value why do we value
it what what does the opportunity cost
of doing that
for go you know so anyhow um
they're very patient with me
but yeah and i hope i hope everybody is
going through those kinds of
evaluations in their mind i think it
wakes people up yeah
you know yeah i think just having that
awareness like you mentioned too of all
the different values that we have i
think it's given us another way to
actually look at those in the mirror and
think about
what our values and what our world view
are you know because even as you
mentioned when you left and came back
it seemed like there was a shift there
there's a little bit of a riffle i mean
obviously we could you know we could get
into that just all the different
covert perspectives and different
pockets of the country but then just you
know even that you caught yourself in
that like judging mode
that i did
the crew all has to be double vaxxed the
crew has to all wear masks anybody
that's interacting with actors because
actors have makeup on that the masks can
smudge and mess up
so uh they have to they have to have the
masks and the uh shield okay you know
they're they're not there's there's all
you know people are having temperature
checks in the morning there was all
these like
super rigorous controls but the second i
stepped outside and i didn't have a mask
on it was like
no time
that was gone yeah yeah that's exactly
what happened so i mean it's that
tension too between because i mean so
the other thing is you were there i
assume you didn't get sick
no different scenario
if something had happened
you caught cohen and then how that could
have also changed your review and i
think some of that has also played out
in a lot of ways too my brother and i
were talking because
i'm in sweden now and no one in sweden
wears masks no one
so i'm interacting with say a thousand
people
right or or directly relax you know i
mean you're in a hall where there's all
right 10 000 people but directly
interacting with a couple hundred maybe
and he's interacting with like six
people
but he's like if i get cove if shawn
gets coved
because he was interacting with people
it's justifiable because he was making
money if i get coveted because i was
visiting my friends then it was just it
was a discretionary
like error or something so
there's these kinds of psychological
uh
like
games that you play with yourself that
that go into
um
you know
and so in economics there's this thing
they call it uh homo economicus
uh and that's the ideal rational actor
the the
entity that will make whatever interest
not gonna tip at a restaurant because
it's not in that person's interest
unless you have a different system so
you you just start realizing like what
you know
what is our obligation to each other
yeah what is our what is our obligation
to each other to
um
and how we you know the only kind of
leadership the best kind of leadership
to me is the only kind of leadership
that's by example and what happens when
you
set an example that you know
doesn't line up with the stated
yeah
there's so many layers to that too
because like your own perspective about
justifying why you're doing what you're
doing versus what other people are
thinking versus on what the outcomes
like you and your brother kind of
depended on
you know if you got uncovered if you've
gotten covert different perspectives on
the outcomes of justification like all
that kind of all mixed together i think
that can it's good for us and i have
then i have all of these friends
uh or you know i i the there's there's
different threads that i'm on and on one
of these threads that i'm on with a lot
of very intelligent very you know
well-educated people
there's a uh
a steady drum beat of um antagonism
towards public policy with regard to
coving and the the memes and the videos
and the yeah uh the things that come
through
uh
they're all smart people these people
i'm describing who are putting it
forward so there's always like some
element in what's being
conveyed that gives you pause
you know and then i go back to my
team and i'm like hey hon what do you
think of this and they're like wow you
can't you get
what are we allowed to discuss
you know what is that what is a
conspiracy
you know conspiracy theory is something
that any two or three people come up
with you know when when is it
bad and when is it you know
like prudent i don't know yeah i don't
know and it's hard to find the truth
beneath everything too with all the i
mean so how you know how quickly someone
can just say something that goes viral
that somehow becomes truthful even
though it's completely
non-factual and just navigating through
that hole and and the the mental
strain
that it puts on people of good will
trying to navigate
those decisions and those emotions and
those
uh you know particularly when you have
people that you're responsible for
now when it comes to
to um
[Music]
rebuilding a society a mental society
yeah where we can you know
relate with each other
just takes um
commitment and focus and i think and
it's exhausting yeah and i know you've
talked about that before too how you see
mental health that's the biggest
challenge that we have
as a nation especially coming out of the
pandemic so and you and just thinking
about you know some of the things you've
done the community like what if what's
been your idea of ways to kind of help
people move through that because it is
you know a lot of people kind of talked
about the second wave being kind of the
mental health crisis not that the crisis
wasn't there before but just the
additional strain of all the isolation
and there's the fear factor people maybe
maybe the
covid
has made it easier for people to have a
mental health discussion because
uh on some on macro level i hope
because
nobody did anything quote unquote wrong
a lot of times in the stigma game
uh the idea of
starting to talk about one's mental
health
um
connotes
failure or you know
that it it means that you've um
you know that there's been some
bad
behavior bad thinking bad
choices bad i don't know what but that
that in some way you're responsible not
just for like you know the decisions you
make and the ramifications of your
decisions but you're responsible for the
very nature of whether or not you're
healthy your food choices your exercise
your sleep
regimen all all those kinds of things
that go into that go into health but
there's you know
that's that stigma i and now everybody
is allowed to talk about wow what does
it mean
that you did night you know
18 months
differently
than anyone in society for the last
couple hundred years even through world
wars nothing happened like this i asked
my father if you remember the depression
he's 91 and he said he remembered it
very well he remembered breadlines his
dad was a scientist but he remembered
certain things and i said what's worse
that or this he said this by a mile he
goes he goes you you
when someone was in trouble during the
depression you could help them
now the best thing you could do to help
somebody was stay away from them
so that
paradigm is uh in inhuman
it's not it's not human when else in
human history i mean there have been
other plagues and other um you know
mass health events and stuff but on this
scale uh you know
um
so but any anyhow i what do i do in a
weird way
you know lord of the
rings may be the biggest thing i ever do
i do a lot of other things like specific
to giving talks and
my my organization stuff like that but
but people you know there's
there's a great speech in the two towers
and sam's looking out and he goes it's
like in the great tales mr frodo it's
like in the great stories mr frodo full
of darkness and danger they were and
sometimes you didn't want to know the
end because how could the end be happy
how could the world go on the way it was
when so much
bad had happened
but in the end it's only a passing thing
this shadow
even darkness must pass and a new day
will come and when the sun shines it'll
shine out the clearer those are the
stories that stayed with you that meant
something even if you're too small to
understand why
i think mr frodo i do understand now
folk in those stories had lots of
chances of turning back only they didn't
they kept going because they were
holding on to something what are we
holding on to them that there's some
good left in this world mr frodo and
it's worth fighting for one of the
greatest features ever in the history of
you know
drama or whatever i'm so lucky i got to
be the one to say that
um and
you know when you when i'm giving talks
mental health speeches to mental health
organizations which i do all the time
um
something about relating my direct
personal experience
uh and
reflecting the direct personal
experience of people in the audience um
often people ask questions and that's
great because then you can engage a
little bit like that um
there's a sense of
uh
security that people feel there's a
sense of relief that people feel not to
be alone in a moment
um
and then i'll do that speech or then
we'll play a little bit of that speech
or something like that and you realize
that like
they're you know in and of itself that
speech is powerful i've had
thousands literally thousands of people
over 20 years
tell me well let's say hundreds at the
least say you know it saved their life
and it got them through a dark time in
their life that they that you know it
gave gave them inspiration it gave them
hope to go on and it it it it gives that
speech gives a prescription
you know
there is good i don't know is there good
isn't there good well in that idea
they're the concept there is good and
it's worth fighting for
um my my mental health uh
kind of exploration is
now is kind of graduated into not
that it's worth fighting for but like
how do you fight yeah
you know
um
so which is uh you know i've got i've
got solutions um
but they're just suggestions that people
have to find them
find it for themselves but that movie
and then
um
you know just
i want my observations about my mother's
life and her experience and my life and
my experience with my family um and the
fact that people are willing to listen a
little bit closer because they recognize
you from a movie or something my that
was my mom's mission her mission was to
uh destigmatize mental health so so i um
so i i steer into that space
where just uh people like well i don't
know if you're comfortable like if i'm
comfortable when i was like 12 my mom
was saying stuff that you're like mom
how could you say like you didn't get
permission before you told that anecdote
you know like well you know and i'm
sorry on the one hand but
then people come up to me later in life
saying you know your mother's book saved
my life you know your mother her her her
fight her her tenacity her um
you know her moxie basically is it gave
them inspiration and yeah so you know at
a time when people weren't really
talking about it much at least in her
profession
well the profession itself had advanced
to a certain level at that point
her her diagnosis i mean if you think
when she got diagnosed as a
i think it was was it called manic
depression then now it's called bipolar
disorder um
there's something else there's another
one too
um she was afraid
of like
padded rooms and straight jackets and
electroshock therapy and being
ostracized and being given thorazine and
like
in her mind when you're mentally unwell
you go away
so the
the vocabulary the science the the
psychopharmacology had all you know met
her where she was in her 40s and then
she decided to just kind of like pick up
this flag like on the battlefield and
just start waving it around because
she was so grateful
that um
she also saw it as a success strategy
for herself
that if she took ownership of her
diagnosis and her treatment and her
you know her her
journey from
places where she behaved very badly
uh in a lot of ways in front of a lot of
people to someone who did that less and
less
and and uh you know she if she took
ownership of that journey that um she
would sort of get credit for it
you get credit for it
from herself from her family we were
probably the last to give her credit for
because
there was a disconnect between
the authority with which she spoke and
the truth of how she lived and you're
like there's a gap there but it didn't
matter to the people who she was
communicating with they were they were
inspired and
so but but that that sort of empowerment
track that she was on i think um
uh was in terms of
larry king was always uh was
you know the first cable news
kind of nighttime news anchor i mean you
had uh
you have peter jennings and dan uh
rather and the other guy but who are
your kind of like you know
male white
of a certain age you know disseminating
the news during the week to let you know
that the world was okay and you know or
whatever so but larry king was the first
like talk show guy to do those sorts of
issues uh war and
and stuff and every time something would
happen in the mental health space muriel
hemingway would be on to deal with
alcoholism
uh uh um rosalind carter
would come on to talk about depression
and my mom was there to talk about
bipolar and they were they you know now
we're all into seeing panels of speakers
on tv but at the time they were doing it
that was pretty rare yeah so she was you
know if somebody
it was usually in response to something
horrible that would happen a shooting or
something like that
but
she would get a third of the time to
respond to those issues and she educated
herself well enough you know late lay
person's educ education about it but you
know sufficient to
impress
psychiatric institute of america who
gave her a big award and
uh pharmaceutical companies who had her
you know
work with them and stuff so i do have my
you mentioned the run third uh running
thing we ended up creating a non-profit
called the run third alliance that's how
you and i met because
um we it had to go virtual it's a 5k
it's a it's a it's a series of after
school running programs for elementary
school kids um so fifth sixth graders uh
fourth fifth sixth graders who uh just a
little bit of a
very low cost uh structured after school
experience that that you know running
that's just so good for kids to get that
physical energy and yeah and uh and then
to connect them
conceptually like with their parents a
little bit and then with the community
abroad and then it culminates in a 5k
run at the it's in mesa arizona we have
like 10 schools 12 schools in mesa
arizona and um
uh red mountain high is the is on their
football field we set up one of those
5k balloon things and nice people you
would get all kinds of sponsors to come
out and it's it's a beautiful thing so
we had to go virtual because of the
because of covid and it occurred to us
as we were trying to figure out like you
know the fundraiser to be ready to
i mean all the programs just folded
when the closest shut up there's like
okay well now so
do we want them to come back online we
don't really have the infrastructure set
up for that we need money to be able to
do it so but as we're putting together
the virtual 5k it just became clear that
um
one of the things we could use the
moment for was to engage
these families
mostly lower income families uh with
mental health
um
concepts
and so um you know when my mom died
right after she died i i
cooked up this idea of the mental health
patty duke mental health project
we never raised enough money to actually
be able to launch it as a proper
instrument legal instrument but we
raised some money and i was like well
let's put some money towards
facilitating a little um dialogue with
these and if not a dialogue but like how
can we flow resources to these folks
yeah um and so we and i really
appreciate the fact that you can't talk
to us about how to think about some of
that so those are the
you know
mental health speeches which i do a lot
um
and those and that
little thing that i just described are
the kind of big
ticket things that i do yeah yeah well i
was definitely appreciate that i was
taken back to something you said earlier
about just a shift it's almost like
people have more permission
to talk about it because you know you
talked about when people were before
it's a lot of times saying what did you
do wrong
you know this happened to you you're at
fault have you noticed that is that
openness still there when you're
engaging the community with the runther
alliance when you're talking to or
there's still some pushback like how do
you navigate that as someone who grew up
with someone who struggled with mental
health and saw kind of both sides of
that
i don't want to report what i think i
see
what i think i see are um
i think there are
the resources that are available to
people are so much more than people
realize there are some great resources
so if people are in need uh everyone is
in need but if but if to some extent or
other but you know if it gets a point
where people feel like they need to
you know talk to a counselor or you know
you know seek some sort of a diagnosis
or something like that
if they ask a little bit
there are routes
you know they'll get routed to places
where they might be able to get
something that they can afford
um you know because a lot of time
there's people are worried about the
expense of that sort of thing you know
but um i mean she said i haven't really
tried it but that michael phelps
promoted thing about talk therapy now
kind of a thing you're like well that's
there you go that's
a lot of times what mostly would be you
know what people need at least to start
is to get autism yeah so um
but i see antagonism
developing along the lines of how people
are coming out of covet
wow and i and i see
it
making people's communication a little
fragile
um
so i think we could do well
to start
you know i had a friend come to la from
new york and he was he was clearly kind
of back in the saddle
you know some people are just you know a
lot of them i mean look
stadiums of people are going to you know
like the country is
back for you know you know in a serious
way yeah um but you know people's
mentality is still there so he came out
and i kept saying you know listen my the
way my wife and kids are
they don't want me to you know go go mix
and mingle in the world and then come
back into their like protected bubble
and he this my good friend and he like
couldn't
he couldn't work with it for a while
until i kind of said it forcefully i'm
like look it will be upsetting to them
if i do that if i come meet on somewhere
outside with matt whatever and it's it's
so i and he he finally was like okay i
totally understand that's fine
but there wasn't there was we did have
to navigate yeah that little space and
i wasn't even the one who was
worried about it
so i then had to turn around i had the
static with him and then i had to turn
around to my guys and be like listen you
guys this is the environment that people
are operating in
so now
behaving responsibly at the extreme end
that you're wanting to
is you know has consequences and we and
we we have to understand what those
consequences are and they they want to
challenge them too they want you know
they want friends they want school they
want a lot of things but but i i just
noticed that there's a look a kind of
furtive look in people's eyes
when they ask questions about
uh you know what's going on post coven
and and i
it makes me sad because i'm
you know i don't know if i'm an empath
in the like clinical sense of it or the
whatever metaphysical sense of it but
i'm very in tune with what
people are thinking and feeling
and you know
i remember i remember when there was a
in 1992
after the verdict within the rodney king
trial and la riots started the 92la riot
started
i remember driving to the grocery store
and
we were like okay well let's you know
let's get some
do a little grocery shopping well
because it's going to be a few days
probably until this all calms down
and i get to the grocery store and
people in
the parking lot were not observing
normal
rules they were not behaving normally
they were parking
a skew
you know they pull into the parking lot
and they'd stop and they'd get out
and you know
you get 20 or 30 people who do that and
the parking lot looks like uh
you know so we go in and people are
they're not in a um they're not in a
panic mode yet but there's this
simmering feeling yeah and so we got in
whatever few little things we weren't
gonna like you know hoard or anything
but the few things we got we we get in
line and we're standing there and the
person checking out
the items is not looking up
or just only looking up
to the extent they need to and i could
see the person's name was i don't know
tom or something i'm like hey tom how
you doing man how are things going
and he looked up and he was and you
could feel
everyone around settled
somebody talked normal wow somebody you
know there was a there was still
a sense of like we know things aren't
right but how are you is a question
about normalcy and we're okay you know
we're holding it together reinforces the
idea of
social cohesion
and so
this current moment this thing that i'm
noticing is like
people's
preset
is something negative
or at least
skeptical yeah and so it's a little bit
of like an emotional barrier that you
have to yeah climb over it's fast it's
subtle you can't really you know to the
untrained eye you might not know what's
going on but uh but i i just figured
that you know thanksgiving is coming in
a couple of weeks uh i don't know when
this when your listeners are gonna hear
this or christmas the holiday seasons
season and you know it's it's bad enough
if you're one you know if one uncle's a
republican and the other one's a
democrat and you just know like oh my
god they're just going to be going on
that you know and so forth um but now
everyone
most people can just get away in those
social settings of saying like
you know well i don't really talk about
politics or uh you know you know what i
haven't really paid much attention to it
or oh it's they're all the same anyway
or you can you can
you know if there's safe harbor in
dismissiveness but when it comes to
covid yeah
everybody's gotta
just devise and i think you're right
because everybody's writing i mean like
you talked about with the the king
rodney king is there's just a level of
tension anxiety that everybody's writing
i think it's a there's a huge variety in
how much
people or how much we're willing to
acknowledge that
in our interactions i think some of us
are very keenly aware that it's there
and it's affecting how we interact and
navigate in the world and some of us
aren't as keenly aware and just kind of
seeing the outcome of it in those and
then things just kind of boil over so
like you were talking about just that
community aspect just taking time to
step back
and say how are you
and you know just those little things
makes a huge difference
um because this you know this is kind of
a unique shared experience
in that sense well i feel like
these kind of conversations and i don't
even know what other forms it takes
but
it takes time to think through a process
and
there everybody's got other stuff going
on
so
to help to give people tools
like hey if you find yourself in this
situation here's a way you know
this is what's at stake
and here are some possible ways for you
to navigate it yeah um
you know in the economics of behavioral
economics is this last chapter we've
been looking at and and there's all
these kinds of prompts they call them
nudges you know what nudges are nudges
in society things like um
um
if the default setting at your work is
that you're opted into a savings plan
where they withhold savings
or you're opted in already to you're not
opted in your the default setting is
you're um participating in
some health care plan or something like
that you have to choose not to do it
people our behavioral tendencies
are if we were more aware of them in the
ways that i'm learning about in these
classes i'm taking yeah i think we might
uh
we might
people should just know that there are
thinking has been done
along the lines of what most of us are
feeling and thinking and it's not that
far away
to be able to access that thinking you
don't have to read the whole book you
don't have to listen to the whole
audiobook you don't have to you know
fully go there there's there there are
ways because people are impatient
you know and and um where people choose
to put their
intention their their
you know
the the substance of their life that
this what they do you know um
but we could all
you know
the seat belt light if you don't put
your seat belt on
there's an actual light that goes off
that tells you and the sound and they
make it mandatory uh that you know the
the so you know and the death rate
in the public policy of doing that
drives it down like what is there in the
mental health space that could be a
blinking light that lets you know like
oh actually you're gonna cause
a lot less expense
to the health care system if you
you know get a good night's sleep or you
you know you eat a sandwich when you're
when you're hungry and you don't let
yourself spiral out of control because
the truth is you're hungry you know like
yeah um
that's the uh that's the key question
and i think they were still trying to
figure out the best way
to do that i mean i think part of it is
having people like you who are sharing
honestly you know about what you
experienced growing up and trying to put
that in front of a lot of different
audiences people had lived experiences
making sure they share but really to
kind of get it ingrained i think that's
the key
piece because it's funny you know as
you're talking about the sleep so my
dad's actually a sleep physician and he
came on you know this podcast a couple
episodes back and was just talking about
some of those things like how sleep
affects your overall health and your
mental health and the importance of
getting good rhythms and you know just
some of the little things that can make
a huge difference but if there's a way
for us to kind of
really have that permeate
and to say do you have any ideas i'm
curious i mean there's someone here well
i mean you've thought about this a
little bit
my sleep schedule uh well i mean
being honest with yourself
about what what's going on in your
environment that's actually affecting
those things i mean i
my sleep schedule i noticed i was like
going to sleep at three and four in the
morning
and you know i'd wake up in the morning
tired or i'd wake up at 11
you know i'd get my six or seven hours i
was just getting them like and out and
it's not like it was affecting my
i mean my i'm professional if i have a
job and i need to be up at seven in the
morning you know i get up at six and
like i'm fine but i have one of those
jobs as an actor where most of the time
i'm actually not working so really it's
like
what do you want to do with your life
and i realized that when that i
experienced a certain kind of stress
associated with my wife and kids
and when they everybody would go to
sleep all of a sudden it was like jazz
hours like this is my time you know like
this is this is time where you know and
and so i would just you know maybe even
just watch movies on tv you know like
watch movies
nothing even you know sometimes the same
movie i'd seen 10 times
but there were some there must have been
something about
that and then like when oh my gosh when
um
when covet hit
i became like a sun worshiper
i would i would set my clock my daily
mental clock based on the half hour or i
would go out and sit down on the on the
patio furniture or walk around with my
shirt off in the backyard
like in shorts like you know they're
like dad what are you doing okay
but like i would literally feel so much
better
and sleep so much regularly my my uh
circadian rhythms
when i was like had a kind of sun
you know regular sun yeah um i then once
we got to a point where i was like guys
i'm now gonna go like for long walks and
runs so we'll get we can pick a route
where you guys are comfortable with it
but i'm not going to not do that it's
with my otherwise i you know it's just i
have to do that so if you need me to
move out you're going to kick me out and
if i keep it i'm going for a six mile
walk right now that's what's happening
um and we so we came up with a
compromise that worked but when i would
do that when i would get six eight nine
ten miles of a walk in a day
sleep like a baby
eat better
actually i could eat like crap
afterwards because i feel like i was and
like earned the right justified it
but i you know
mental uh uh sleep hygiene your dad's
gonna love that he's asleep
you know it's weird here it's it's uh
it's 3 30 here
so have you seen any have any of the
ships gone by yet i haven't seen it
we have picked the wrong hour to do this
because in like an hour these ships
these massive really cool ships are
going to go right by the window but it
gets dark here
now
like four by four o'clock within the
next half hour 40 minutes it's dark
that's it
that
f's with the mind that's true
and i i uh but there's i found a place
where i can park the car
the swedish they're so organized
everything is so well like you know
organized no joke and
the there's these walkways that are
really well lit and i can go for like a
five mile walk and i'll go it i'll put
on my it's cold out it's like you know
32 degrees out but i'll get my my
clothes on i'll go for a walk and i'm
moving one's physical body
outside
is
a uh and
drinking water those are my two you know
some people can take certain drugs you
know
my mom you know hers was lithium she was
very religious about it she talked about
it but
whatever
drug therapy or
talk therapy or whatever people go
through as they're building their
wellness strategy for themselves
moving and it's hard for people who
can't move their bodies
yeah it's hard you know you know why
like in in uh
convalescent homes they wheel them out
the patients out to be in the sun for a
certain period of time
um
so i would just encourage people to find
outdoor time doing anything
yeah and so many pieces of that too
because i mean your ex like the way the
exercise
impacts the brain which makes it you
know easier for us to just kind of
navigate through or just be in the sun
having a regular schedule it sounds like
what you've done is just found out what
those are for you you know for your mom
it might be
isolated talk therapy yeah
it's i i think often about my wife's
family in indiana
her father was a firefighter and a clean
operator her mom worked in a foundry
these are working-class people and
a lot of times the conversations about
men it's changed now now in that
community
cvs is right down the street everybody
knows where to go they go to the doctor
to get their med like people are
oriented towards it now i think the next
step in the mental health
uh
you know game is
is for people to start refining their
questions and and
uh raising their expectations for what
their own uh
you know capabilities are
um and and and and managing that
that process so um
but yeah uh what can i say the the
the other thing is
to move away from sleep for a second
there's a lot of discussion now i just
gave a talk with a group called i think
they were called brain health or
something
um
what was the phrase they used it was so
good it just has to do with
language
the vocabulary surrounding
the conversation of mental health the
mental wellness and mental illness
and i find that
one of the things i'm able to do in my
speech is because i just don't care i
mean i always say at the beginning of my
speeches to mental health organizations
and group community groups or whatever
like i'm not a professional
you know you have to seek your own
uh you know professional medical
guidance and everything else but but
i'll speak generally about what i think
and feel and one of the things that i
speak to is i'm very critical of the
mental health
corporate and the mental health
medical
community
because i think the language that is
used
the the general temperament has improved
i think over the last 25-30 years where
people's you know
healthcare providers mental health
providers are genuinely interested in
contributing to the wellness of the
person they're not just like dealing
with a problem
um
but even even well-intentioned people
use phrases
that are suppressive
and if we you know
you know
people with bipolar disorder in
particular since my like area
um
are highly suggestible
and like really
highly in tune
with judgment
what's being said and you know if the
mind is going a thousand miles an hour
which it's want to do
and you get like a little monkey wrench
thrown into it
that's bad
so people have to be accountable for
their own reactions to what they hear
but when you call someone there was a
word that i haven't heard as much in the
last few years but they were calling
people sufferers
a bipolar sufferer
they're like come on man we gotta do
better than that
because if you're a bipartisan
is there is it like a broken arm does it
mend
if you if you have a bipolar mood
disorder is there a fixed stop point or
are you being given a death sentence
when you're told that you have a bipolar
mood disorder and if you're a bipolar
sufferer
well
we have now consigned you to suffering
for the rest of your life
and that is not
um accurate it's not an accurate
thing to do
you know i mean i think people might
feel like
well at least someone has empathy
you know if you say someone's a sufferer
you go oh i don't want you to be
suffering i see that you're suffering i
i hear you i feel that you're suffering
i i want to help take action they cannot
alleviate
but there's there's there's just a
conversancy that happens and there's
like there's optimistic speak and
there's
little things yeah yeah i think that's
so important that like to have even some
of these like back and forth
conversations i think are critical
because i mean to your point i think you
know within some of the training circles
people are trying to get away from or
trying to pay attention to their own not
that they weren't before but their own
body language and their responses and
how that influences
people that they're talking with but i
think like just to have this type of a
level of candid conversation is critical
because even within the field you know
there's been a shift from
trying to get away from saying you are
bipolar like that defines you
right and right obviously has
lots of negative consequences to trying
to say this is something that someone
has but as you pointed out even that can
be a shift i think people are now trying
to say well you are struggling someone
who has bipolar is struggling with
bipolar is suffering with bipolar but
then to your point if people don't have
these conversations don't even think
about what
that word suffer
does or how that's being
interpreted by the person so i feel like
this has to be i don't think it's fair
enough but it has to be an ongoing
conversation
between clinicians
scientists family members and those who
are working i think one of the things
you get both sides it's informative one
of the things that i think can help is
if people
orient themselves to the
to the premise that like
people who are having an issue
can successfully navigate the issue
there are ways for it to be there yeah
so it doesn't you know the thing that's
hard is is
you know usually there's uh when when
the moment at which people talk about
focus
think about seek treatment whatever
there's usually crisis involved
so
the
what's
interesting to think about i think is is
to note that like a crisis moment on a
timeline does not have to define like
the end point we've been many of the
other
points along that along that continuum
so you know navigate you know mental
health challenges uh you know uh so the
one group was talking about you know
brain health that's what they were
called their brain health and they're
like the brain is an organ like you know
your heart is an organ you have to have
heart health you have to have liver
health kidney health you have to have
brain health yeah
and um
[Music]
so you know
they're such complex instruments our
brains
what an amazing thing
what an amazing thing like the
neurological
kind of carnival that's happening
you know i mean i'm at an age now where
memory i'm starting to
you know
you know i'm wondering if i've if i've
topped up like that's it i've captured
my memory things like you know my
father's 91 his memory is incredible he
somehow finds pathways for ideas to get
to names or numbers you can spit out a
number and he can remember numbers
things but i i find that my recall like
so what the what's going on what's going
on in the chambers of my mind is it is
it starting to atrophy is it starting to
you know i love my studies
i love my studies i mean my it's so hard
it's so hard and what i know would have
taken me you know two hours to do in my
early twenties is taking six hours to do
now that i'm 50 and i don't know if
that's just because i don't know why
that is but i
i
i just marvel at the human mind and
what's
i hope that that technology and medicine
is
accelerating quickly enough
that
i mean you're young you're how old are
you i see you got 23. i'm not not as
young as yeah not as young as i was
so so i'm 50. so by the time i'm 65
which is like what retirement is that
officially retirement age or retirement
age is older now 70 72 i don't know well
public policy that's what i'm studying
like it says i'm an actor we never
retire i'm retiring every time i finish
a job i'm retired i'm coming out of
retirement because i got another job but
the um
but like will there be technologies
available
to help stimulate the mind or help
repair things within the brain uh if
that's something you're working on let
me not distract you anymore
people are working on it but to be
honest i mean it's one of those
interesting topics because some of the
things
we're learning
shouldn't be surprising in a sense but
people are trying to understand okay how
does exercise actually
impact process and even all the things
you know
being
i was not academically but being just
engaged
in things deep conversations and studies
and things like that just keeping your
mind active and all the positive effects
that has i don't study aging per se but
some of it is just looking at those
natural practices those god-given
practices that we know we should do that
actually have positive effects for our
brains as well but in that sense a lot
of the research that people are doing
are trying to figure out what's
happening when things go awry so when
you know when dimension sits in or
alzheimer's or ways we can kind of
prevent some of those processes and
things like that and to be honest some
of the it's not a complete 100
protective effect but some of those
things like exercise and engaging in
intellectual activities also seem to
have some protective effects so people
are looking into how that's happening
but i mean that's an open question
whether there'll be
you know therapeutic interventions or
technology to uh that's you know the
adult age-old question of uh
not immortality but kind of keeping our
mental faculties in a sense as long as
we can
i mean you know we
there are such
dangers
associated with having eight and a half
billion people
on this little blue spinning rock
you know there are
like our food supply
our uh you know i mean
disease like we've just been you know
like these kind of pandemics that you
can have
you know just
the environment like pollution you know
all of there's so many
things that are um
really
just
pressures weighing down on civilization
on humankind
but one of the awesome things is that
really smart people like you
are working all over the world on coming
up with some of these kinds of um
insights and you know therapies and and
you know just
so i i
i hope i live long enough
to be able to
uh
see
you know
dementia
would be great wouldn't it be great if
you could really take the teeth out of
dementia i'm gonna be great
um
and so yeah
yeah
yeah i don't know
i think again you know just kind of full
circle that all ties back to community
too i mean i loved how you talked about
just
the impact i mean yeah there are so many
people on there and that community feels
like it can go both ways and i think
we've obviously seen that in the last
year like the positive effects of what
we need in community what we can learn
from each other and how that actually
impacts our brains too and helps it
makes it easier for us to kind of
navigate through life just the reward
that comes from those social
interactions but on the flip side
all the angst and antagonism you know
even as you're talking about some of the
covet rifts that can also come
from being in community so i mean it's a
little bit of both but i mean i think in
a lot of ways um like the research
enterprise in a sense has has seen that
as well because oftentimes not to make
it too global but scientists obviously
work in community too we need community
to kind of have innovative ideas and
think about new ways of doing things but
i feel like people got a greater sense
of that because sometimes people can
just be like well this is my project i'm
gonna go down this lane laser focused
work on that but without having those
touch points and interactions just how
much harder it was for people to
actually do that work in isolation um
and so in a sense it's like a um an
awakening of those who are doing the
work realizing oh yeah we also need that
community too even though we may be
studying these things
we can't actually remove ourselves from
the equation um and again i was just you
know just thinking about you know as
you're talking about your mom and some
of those things like the importance of
community just in terms of mental health
like are we having conversations across
the board with different folks who can
actually inform how we talk about mental
health you know are people trying to do
one thing and talk about things in a
better way but actually making it more
difficult for people who are kind of
going through it so i think it's all
critically important so as you continue
in this world of any like any words of
wisdom for for us as we you know try and
think towards getting to a better place
and just how we talk about and address
mental health like both the wellness
aspect and some of the challenges i mean
it drops a lot of nuggets already but
yeah i mean
there's this moment where people go from
being generous to being selfish
you know if there's it's amazing when
there's someone in need
how people are like oh
help that person
but
then there's other ways in which it's
like people pull back
and i think
we have to at the very least
[Music]
see in ourselves when we're leaning
forward and when we're leaning back
with others with ourselves too i guess a
little bit but with others meaning just
um
yeah i talk about this a lot when i give
in speeches like
you can only do so much
you're only going to be as successful as
you can be
you can do everything right
and the person you want to be helpful
with
it's not going to work
yeah
so
the important thing is to
mourn the loss of
you know
that
whatever level of help you're trying to
do
that isn't gonna be whatever that
whatever that piece is that's a failure
mourn the loss of that and then help
wow then the quality of your help will
be based in
you know
reality and based in
um
agency of the person that you're trying
to help
uh which is really
almost all the time like the only way it
works you know except the person wants
to
move in there and they're in a direction
for themselves um
you know and people have to protect
themselves too because um
you know you can try there's a
lifeguard analogy where you swim out the
lifeguard swims out and then the person
drowns the lifeguard because they're
spazzing out too much that happens a lot
in the mental health space
so you know i think
that was sort of the second half what i
should have said first is like just be
willing to think
you know to be willing to to engage
these ideas a lot of times the subject
matter is so big
that people it's just too much to even
think about yeah but if you if you sort
of empower yourself
that you can hear a little bit and
that's enough you don't have to like
you know you don't have to you don't
have to overwhelm yourself you don't
have to commit yourself to a course of
you're not going to be a physician you
know you're
you know
maybe there will be useful piece of
information if you open your eyes in a
certain moment to a certain exchange
that's happening or something like that
and maybe there won't
you know i mean i think i think people
want um
you know 100 return on time investment
you know
oprah rep rep recommends a book you read
that book you get the value from that
book 100 return you know uh it's only
worth that sometimes people will go to a
website or they'll go to a thing and
they'll invest a little bit of time and
if there isn't return on that investment
somehow that's experienced as a defeat
or as a as a unwilling sacrifice
so i think if on the journey for our own
mental wellness and for i mostly think
about others
for for myself
you know
for everybody communication is critical
like you said those kinds of
conversations sensitivities it doesn't
have to be conversations if you just
have sensitivities
um
i was watching an episode of friends
oh i was making a juice and uh
they the thing that makes that show work
is that they all as they all lie to each
other throughout ten seasons they lie to
each other they
they make mistakes at each other they
compromise each other whatever but
ultimately what always brings those
characters back to each other is they're
listening to each other and they are
sensitive to each other and i feel like
we if we're sensitive to
our own words we're speaking to others
if we
protect ourselves if we recognize that
we're really sensitive to what somebody
else is saying
you know somebody comes into your
environment and you're like i'm not
gonna let this person
light me up right now i'm just not gonna
let it happen and you know then they say
something boom and you're off to the
races mentally yeah you you know you
have to develop
um
my wife's grandfather
was always late grandfather he died he
was 86 i think you got 20 years ago more
than 25 years ago
um
maybe 24 years ago he he was always
macgyvering stuff
you know what i mean like at one point i
walked out in our garage he was staying
with us in our little two-bedroom house
in sherman oaks because he the winter in
indiana he couldn't handle it they came
out with us and he was and he would
open the garage and sit in the chair
looking at traffic looking at the
traffic in the neighborhood he by 7 30
he could tell you everyone's business
wow
but he walked over to the tool chest and
he had rigged up like a
a coat hanger
with a thing and another thing and he
was using it to hang his keys
and i looked at it and i was like
this old timer has just like entertained
himself
with coming up with his little thing and
there were a million things like that if
you went and looked at his toolbox in
his shed in indiana there were a million
things like that i think our i think our
mental health can be like that we can
come up with little strategies that will
like
help us in a moment or maybe it won't
and or maybe it helped us at one point
and it's not gonna help us now and
that's fine but that that um
spirit of innovation yeah yeah that
that people have for
objects
if we find some way to do that with our
mind you know i mean i suppose if you're
80d like how many times you where you
put the things on the thing it matters
or something but but you know what if
you what if you set something there and
you say every time i see that i'm saying
i love myself i mean i don't know
whatever but yeah whatever it is play
games come up with with little
um because what's fun is you'll get lost
in it
in some little game some little
technique you're coming up with for
yourself to be able to like you know
pass the time
and make yourself calm yourself or
get yourself like going you know um
you know i i know um
because i was sleeping late all the time
i could see where the we had a palm tree
in our back backyard and i could tell
where the shadow was in the palm tree
wow every day right when i wake up i'd
look up and i'd be like so bummed if the
shadow was
was over this way because i knew it
meant like i had slept like it was past
noon or something and then
so what i would do is i would look out
and when the palm tree got when the
shadow of the palm tree got to this one
particular thing i would get up and go
run wow
i use the shadow of the palm tree as my
prompt to get up and go right it's so
stupid i don't think i've ever told
anybody it works right so and but what
happens is setting the rhythm for
yourself and then your brain is
expecting that and then you're just
going with it
and then someone will discover it
you know someone would be like they'll
see you thinking about something or
you'll you'll be there has to be a
spirit of play is what i'm saying yeah
if you can have a spirit of play about
your own it can't just be about the
struggle and the the thing there has to
be
some way to engage other people and i
know like my wife and i
she'll see something that you go you're
doing that with that aren't you like
yeah
and like well just it's like a little
husband-and-wife thing where like she
knows me she knows that i'm like sending
setting my mental clock where i'm you
know petting my mental mood
in a certain way that uh you know that
she
she appreciated
yeah yeah i mean the research backs you
up just having like that space
to play or do other things like how how
resetting that is for us and just
protective in a lot of ways and helps
people kind of get through challenges
too so your great grandfather he was he
was onto something
[Laughter]
yeah oh my gosh well i appreciate you
taking the time and just you know all
the insights that you shared i know this
the listeners will enjoy kind of hearing
what you've been up to in the past and
just you know i i really appreciate the
way you personalized it too kind of took
us on that journey so thanks so much for
taking the time to jump on dr a you are
a beautiful
human being and i i wish you
every six continued success with the um
with the podcast with your family
with your beautiful family and uh you
know how to get a hold of me if you ever
need me for anything
[Music]